Hình hành án rất sự thành phố Hàn Nội sát nhận, tinh đến ngày 15, và ông chính văn quyết là bà lê
thì học giúp tiếp tục lột thiên một nghiệm 1 trong tỷ đồng.
Năng tổng số tiên khắc phục hậu khỏa vụ án của ông quyết và ra định lên khoảng 20 năm trong tỷ đồng,
đủ để khắc phục tàn bộ hậu khỏa của vụ án thao tụng chương khoán.
Theo bản án sơ thầm, số tiên bị gáo chính văn quyết, cư chù tịch tập đoàn Ebbler C,
cùng 2 em gái là chính thị miếng hế và chính thị thuyên gà phải khắc phục trong vụ án này là 20,
đủng trăm sóng mới bệnh tỷ đồng.
Trước đó, đổ thằng tâm năm 2019, tòa ANNNZ thành phố Hàn Nội đã tuyên phạt bị gáo chính văn quyết
mề tám năm tụ về tổ lửa đạo chíng đặt tại sao?
Ban năm tụ về tổ thấu tụng thị trường chương khoán, tổng cả 2 tổ gên là 2 miếm 1 năm tụng.
Hái em gái bị gáo quyết là chính thị miếng hế và chính thị thuyên gà bị tư lần lột 1 năm tụ vào tám năm tụ cùng
về 2 tổ gên Nếu trên.
Tần 1,5 bí káo trong vụ án, cùng một trăm 8,5 bí hại và 8,5 xong mấy xấu người có quyết lợi, nghĩa vụ linh quan thẳng cáo.
Theo kế hoạch, 2,5 bẩy thẳng xấu tới đây, toàn nhân dân cấp cao tại Hà Nội sẽ đưa ra sẽ sử phúc thẩm vụ án xe ra tại tập đòn Eplosy và các đơn vị linh quan.